et nous continuons sur l'agriculture
justement circuits courts ou circuits de
proximité acheter et manger local c'est
peut-être un des nouveaux engagements
citoyens
si on a l'image d'une région
ile-de-france urbanisées les habitants
de saint quentin en yvelines le savent
les champs des agriculteurs ne sont
jamais très loin pour nous en parler ce
soir en plateau avec nom mélanie poker
conçoit ram et la méfiance or floral les
villes de france ces mêmes 49 % de sa
surface qui est agricole
il y à plus de 5000 exploitation dans la
région tous secteurs confondus
tout à leur faudra nous avait appuyé sur
le terme proximité alors faut savoir
qu'on peut manger local sans
nécessairement passer par un circuit
court sans qu'ils aient pas beaucoup
d'intermédiaires
jérôme comme le directeur du centre
régional de valorisation et d'innovation
agricole et alimentaire nous donne des
précisions
l'agriculteur qui est en bois 60 bornes
de paris qui livre son collègue qui
validerait avis qui ensuite va livrer
les plombs circuits courts passé trop
d'intermédiaires
alors que ils méritent de libre est
aussi bien que le péruvien qui a un
bureau à rungis et en manara jc qui dort
agisse de la librairie d'école ça fait
la proximité est de plus en plus
plébiscités oui parce que selon le
ministère de l'agriculture et le cabinet
naturel marketing institute 71% des
français préfèrent acheter des produits
locaux
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
visiteurs du salon d'agriculture pouvoir
s'ils recherchent eux aussi le commerce
local
je vis de la campagne je vais dans les
faire directement
j'ai acheté la viande là où ils élèvent
les ports les
la viande de boeuf là où ils élèvent les
boeufs ça fait travailler les gens des
régions mais pourquoi parce que c'est
nul à du naturel et oui nous on est d'un
peu de la campagne donc on va aux
producteurs et même dans notre jardin
nous avons ce qu'il faut pour nous
alimenter sainement complètement
complètement bas parce que c'est
directement du producteur au
consommateur par quoi
enfin le bord des routes quand ils
vendent directement ou alors par chez
moi j'ai des gens qui ont des fermes
parce que j'habite à marmande et donc on
l'a entendu elle est directement aux
producteurs à la ferme faire attention à
la provenance c'est ce qu'il vient
d'entendre et cette volonté est aussi
ressentie par le cervia je pense le
consommateur aujourd'hui il est sans fil
à l'origine de tant premier est
l'origine de 100 produits
c'est pas le circuit court l'origine de
100 produits s'est produit 20 et 30 km
lille ap trois intermédiaires pour le
consommateur c'est pas grave
par contre le même produit qui aurait
fait 3000 km par intermedia à boulder on
a parlé du local mais il ya aussi le
circuit court est souvent le salon de
l'agriculture c'est le moignan pour les
agriculteurs de se faire connaître pour
favoriser donc la proximité et c'est le
cas de la ferme de viltain on en a parlé
tout à l'heure elle est située à jouy en
josas leur activité principale c'est
donc le lait ils élèvent leur bétail
font l'attrait transforme le relais qui
vendent ensuite dans leurs boutiques
donc ce salon de l'agriculture ils
rencontrent leurs clients professionnels
mais aussi les particuliers
on va présenter la ferme au public
francilien ça va être notre
notre clientèle beaucoup nous
connaissent déjà mais certains ne nous
ont jamais connu
donc on a
a mis en place des vitrines pour faire
découvrir les produits ça fait 28 ans
qu'on est ici tous les ans
chaque année on a un stand différent
pour nous c'est vraiment très important
et en toute bienveillance on est on est
vraiment très content d'être ici
présenté notre notre ferme notre concept
notre cueillette la laiterie donc on l'a
vu mélanie les agriculteurs cherchent à
se faire connaître
et si nous justement particuliers ou
cherchent à consommer local et qu'on ne
sait pas où trouver les produits est ce
que vous avez quelques pistes à nous
donner alors si vous souhaitez floral où
vous devenir local locavore vous pouvez
favoriser le commerce du coin l'artisan
le boucher vous pouvez aussi le
sensibiliser à se fournir auprès de
producteurs locaux
vous pouvez vérifier les étiquettes des
produits que vous souhaitez acheter et
le cervia dont on parlait tout à l'heure
a lancé mangeons local en ile de france
il référence beaucoup de produits et
sept produits sont identifiées par un
logo
il y à un deuxième site ou sur lequel on
peut aller voir c'est le ministère de
l'agriculture qui lui référence beaucoup
d'initiatives locales
merci beaucoup mélanie et pour
rencontrer les agriculteurs locaux vous
avez hostile jusqu'à ce dimanche donc le
6 mars pour vous rendre au salon de
l'agriculture afin de leur poser toutes
vos questions